Jennifer Lopez and her daughter Emmie  looks so much alike  here are five times the shades of blue  star and her adorable look-alike  daughter were totally twenty they love  it they love it in this throwback pic of  herself as a youngster that JLo posted  to Instagram on her birthday it makes me  emotional on Mother's Day while the two  cuddled up with Emmys twin brother Max  rocking matching top knots and big  smiles they're so big and so amazing  while dancing at a wedding in  coordinating high ponytails on the  purple carpet at the home premiere in  2015 in pastel lace front dresses and  finally in this super cute snapchat pic  of Emmy and her momma with pink flower  crowns on the mother of two wrote in the  caption quote me and this beautiful  princess I really feel blessed  you